one of the casting directors at the
audition they had their fax machine on
in the room so
you know
being invited to one of prince's
parties while we were doing the show and
we found we got an email
20 minutes before the show ended that we
were all invited
to an after party that prince was
throwing
we all went and prince performed
at this after party and i was very very
starstruck
i couldn't believe that i was at a
prince party
let alone the man was performing like
not that far away from me it was pretty
epic
last time i gave someone a compliment
was
uh this morning to my fiance
anthony about his music that he's
working on
last time i received a compliment was
from anthony
on a tv show that i'm writing the last
time i laughed
so hard that i cried
was when we were talking about how
anthony
[Music]
we were talking about how anthony um he
had to have a wig
towards the last month of
him being in hamilton um because he was
doing she's got to have it
and they had to cut his hair for the
show so he was doing double shows
basically he was like filming she's
gotta have it and
still doing hamilton and they put this
wig on him
that was renee's old wig and you know it
was a temporary one until they like
made him one they didn't show the cast
the wig before
we went on so we were all shocked
while we were performing and they
couldn't even get through my shop
without laughing
and every time he would like look at one
of us on stage
we would start bursting it was one of
the funniest shows we've
ever done just trying to survive
last time i ate something unexpected and
loved it
jackfruit the other day my friend is
vegan
and um she had this like
packet of jackfruit that you just open
up put some olive oil in and you
and you you know just make it like that
and it was really spicy
and flavorful and tasted a little bit
like meat which i was very
surprised last time i had an awkward
audition
one of the casting directors at the
audition they had their fax machine on
in the room so you know
it's very awkward for me because i'm
just trying to say the lines
over a fax machine
[Music]
you know listen you gotta have a lot of
focus
when you're performers sometimes you
know it just
just happens subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going